Khloe Kardashian is worried Lamar Odom  could die I feel really strongly there's  only one outcome on sunday's episode of  Keeping Up with the Kardashians Lamar's  health drama continued he was like I'm  having really bad cravings it was like  five steps backwards I don't even know  what to do no great and I said you know  like you could die right now right 36  year old former NBA star's addiction  issues and his road to recovery have  been a constant struggle on the show and  Khloe has been Lamar's rock throughout  his ongoing health problems why do I  treat him better than I treat myself  since the episode was shot the 32 year  old reality star filed for divorce from  lamar for a second time ET caught up  with Odom back in April where he opened  up about the former couple's  relationship we've been through a lot so  it won't ever stop  you